زعيم كوريا الشماليه عنده ثلاثه اولاد
اسمائهم واي معلومات عنهم مو معروفه ولا
حتى كانوا شاف اي منهم في الاعلام الان في
اثنين ما احد عمره شافهم او يعرف عنهم
الشيء لكن من كم شهر ظهرت معالم المره
الاولى بنته اللي عمرها يقدر بنت تسعه
وعشره سنوات ومن وقتها في نوفمبر ظهرت
معاه اربعه مرات اخرها من كم يوم في عرض
خلال عرض عسكري كبير احتفالا بالذكرى
الخامسه والسبعين لتاسيس جيش البلاد
الاعلام الكوري الشمالي وصفها بابنه
الزعيم الفاضله والاعلام الغربي بيقول
انها ابنه المفضله وانه جالس بيجهزها تكون
خليفه في الحكم واللي زادت تكهنات عن
اختيار كليب لابنتها انها تكون خلف له هو
اصدار عدد من الطوابع البريديه الجديده
خمسه منها بتحمل صورتهم مع بعض
كم يوم معروف عنه القرارات والاوامر
الغريبه وفي قرار جديد مختص في موضوع بنته
هذا شاغل العالم فكم اصدقرار رئاسي بيمنع
تسميه اي بنت باسم بنته
ومو بس كده تخيلوا انه قرر كمان انه اي
احد مسمي بنته بهذا الاسم يتواصل فورا مع
الادارات الرسميه علشان تغير اسمها وبحسب
مصادر في القرار بيقول انه هذا اسم مخصص
لذوي اعلى درجات الكرامه فقط عموما يعني
لو وصلت الحكم حتكون رابع جيل من اسره كم
يحكم كوريا الشماليه والانثى كمان